So now we can describe to you the
lock algorithm. Basically the lock algorithm takes to arguments.
One is, this name domino that is associated
with this particular lock. And, and it's also taking
my queue node, the one that I am providing, to say that this is my queue node,
please queue me into this lock request queue. And
when I make this call it could be that
I'm in this happy state, in which case, I don't
have any lock requesters ahead of me. But if it turns
out that, when I come in there is somebody is
using this lock, then I'm going to join this que. And has
to be done atomically. There are two things going on
here in joining this queue atomically. What I do is, I
set the last pointer. This list is always pointing to
the last requester. So, it used to point to this guy,
he was the only requester. I came along, so
we had to fix up this list so that this,
and pointer is going to point to me, the last
requester. And I also had to fix up, the current
requestor point to me. And once I have done
that, then I can await the predecessor, namely this guy,
to signal me, by spinning on the got-it variable that
is associated with my data structure. And the other thing
that I would do as part of joining this
queue is to set my next point at null, because
there is nobody after me, I just made the
lock call. Notice that when I'm joining this queue, I'm
doing two things simultaneously. One is, I'm taking the
pointer that was pointing to him and making it point
to me. And I also need the coordinates of
the previous guy so that I can set his next
pointer to point to me. So I have to do
this double act. So this has to be done atomically
as well. So joining the queue, essentially, is a double
act of breaking a link that used to exist here, make
it point to me, and get the coordinates of this
guy, so that I can fix him up. And remember that
this is happening simultaneously. Perhaps with other guys trying to do
the same thing, joining this queue. And therefore, this operation
of breaking the queue and getting the coordinate
of my predecessor has to be done atomically. And
in order to facilitate that, we will propose having
a primitive operation called fetch and store. And atomic
operation, and the semantics of this fetch and store
operation is that when you make this call and
give it two arguments, L and Me. What this
fetch and store is going to do is, it's going to
return to me what used to be contained in
L, so what used to be contained in L is
my predecessor. So I'll get that, and I'll get
the coordinates of this guy. And at the same time
it's also storing into L a new node that
is the pointer to the new node that is me.
And so that is what is being accomplished by this.
The double act that I mentioned of getting my predecessors
coordinates and setting this guy to point to me is
accomplished using this fetch-and-store operation.
It's an atomic operation. And clearly
the architecture is not having this fetch and store instruction
you have to simulate that with a test and set instruction.